united airlines flight 93 was the last
of the four hijack jetliners to take off
it was the only one to not make it to
its intended target the u.s capitol the
passengers and crews stormed the cockpit
in an attempt to regain control of the
aircraft it crashed in a field in rural
pennsylvania killing everyone on board
their heroism will be remembered today
at a memorial in shanksville
pennsylvania nicole killian is there
nicole good morning
good morning to you dana president biden
and former president bush will pay
tribute to the 40 lives lost that day
last night a vigil was held here at the
memorial with a lantern lit for each
victim it drew quite a crowd and today
around 500 family members and invited
guests are expected to attend this
morning's ceremonies which will be the
most they've ever had
20 years later it's one of those things
where it feels
like it's been a really long time and
then on the other hand it feels like
it's only been a few minutes time knows
no bounds for emily schenkel who lost
her godmother lorraine bay two decades
ago when united flight 93 came hurtling
to the ground in this pastoral
pennsylvania field she was a flight
attendant for 37 years
if you can think of somebody who just
absolutely loved their job that was her
emily will never know if lorraine was
part of the arduous struggle between the
passengers and crew and the hijackers
that ultimately prevented another attack
but their heroism was enough to inspire
emily to name her daughter after her it
was just important to me that if i had a
daughter i would name her that just to
make sure that the name carried on and
the memory of her carried on it is that
legacy that colonel christopher whalen
also wants to instill in his
nine-year-old son
his cousin richard guadagno was on board
why should we never forget you never
forget because you don't want to forget
the sacrifices that were made this was
the first striking back
against terror on this plane and we need
to remember that so that 20 30 40 years
from now there are people who are
carrying on the memory of this site not
only for the 40 but for the world
much of the focus will be on the flight
93 victims but also the town of
shanksville less than 300 people live
here and i spoke with a long time
resident who was here that day and so
they really see
their role as caretakers of this
memorial some have developed
relationships with these families over
the past 20 years and they believe that
it's their duty to carry on the legacy
as well jeff nicole thank you very much